Jennifer Lopez says she wants more kids
I wish I could have a lot more the
superstar is a proud mama to eat your
old twins Max and Emmy there are so big
and so amazing and happy but on Thursday
at the shades of blue for your
consideration event in LA
JLo revealed to ET she's open to
expanding her family I wish I could have
a lot more I wish I don't know if it's
in the cards for me but it's something I
would love to do why the 46 year old
isn't busy being supermom she's working
she's got her all I have Vegas residency
show and her NBC cop drama shades of
blue which got picked up for a second
season this show is so intense and the
show is does take a lot out of you as
the character is like always on the edge
and it's it puts you in a certain state
of mind for like 12 14 hours a day you
know four or five days a week it's tough
what an Emmy nomination means yeah sure
I mean it would be amazing there's
always a goal like when your little girl
want to win an Oscar one day I want to
win an Emmy here but then as I've been
in the business so long the reward is
actually being able to do this for a
living
I really feel blessed and all that would
just be icing on the cake